it was good to hear him speak about it
you could tell was passionate you know
the last 10 minutes you know he went in
he went in and I was like now that's
what you get slapped for
um what I was saying was but see that
was what you've heard was somebody that
was hurt right and somebody that was
Finding their way to heal in that moment
now that we all said it right I did my
special that was about all of it because
from my perspective I know the three of
them right they're my friends and you
know I felt like I had to talk about it
because it affected my journey and
that's what God loves me is and I think
that now if I had it my way I would pull
the the three of them into the
principal's office and go we have to
stop this